ernsthafte es geht es auch leiser
es ist wahr ist dass es nicht
ich muss mal ganz kurz ausmachen ich
wollte nämlich gerade mein video machen
ja so sieht es bei uns nämlich immer aus
wenn ich gerade video drehen möchte muss
der murat immer staubsaugen und das ist
natürlich sehr sehr laut
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein neues baustellen
update und zwar wisst ihr ja dass wir
bei uns zu hause also unser neues
zuhause
dabei wird gerade gadgets ein die
natürlich sehr praktisch sind ich möchte
mir nämlich den alltag so gut es geht
vereinfachen
und um eben viele viele gadgets bei uns
zuhause einzubauen habe ist natürlich
auf den messen gut informiert auer haben
unsere freunde natürlich auch gefragt
die schon gebaut haben was könnt ihr uns
in empfehlen und auch meine zuschauer
haben ganz ganz viel empfohlen und so
sind wir auch zum entschluss gekommen
bei uns zu hause muss auf jeden fall
eine zentrale staubsauger anlage 1 sehen
und jetzt sind wir gerade schon derzeit
beim einbau ihr kennt das ja auch alle
wahrscheinlich werden auch hier bei uns
in der wohnung kurat mach aus wir haben
bei uns hier in der wohnung momentanen
ganz normalen staubsauger das ist auch
wirklich ein sehr gutes auge und das
auch noch alles weg aber ihr kennt die
typischen probleme man stolpert über den
sauger drüber der ehemann zog genau dann
wenn die kinder schlafen oder die
ehefrau sorgt genau dann wenn borussia
dortmund murat gegen wen spielt gegen
die bayern
man hat immer diese szenarien was bei
uns auch schon ganz oft passiert ist
dass wir uns die möbel kaputt geschlagen
haben oder auch die fußleisten hier bei
uns an der wand und es kommt einfach
dadurch zustande dass man den sauger
hinter sich her zieht dann bleibt da
irgendwo mal hängen und dann knallt man
natürlich mit voller wucht entweder
gegen das schienbein oder gegen die
möbel
wir haben auch bei uns das problem mit
den treppen wir haben dann nämlich noch
dieses tür schutzgitter wegen ela damit
sie nicht abhaut und zum nachbarn auf
die straße rennt und da muss man
natürlich den staubsauger erst einmal
über das gitter tragen und dann die
treppe runter tragen und dann habe ich
das problem dass das kabel nicht
ausreicht und ich um dort zu saugen in
verlängerungskabel benutzen muss was
natürlich ziemlich nervig ist ja und was
ich ziemlich nervig finde ist natürlich
auch das staubsaugerbeutel da ständig
voll ist dann müssen wir alle vier bis
fünf wochen etwa wechseln ich weiß
freunde von uns die haben haustiere und
dem ist in denen sogar alle drei wochen
wechseln einfach
den ganzen katzen und hunde haaren den
wollten nur alles raus und wieder rein
also ich wurde soll erst dann einfach
aus ja kein wunder stinkt das dann immer
beim staubsaugen kurator ganz ganz nah
und feinstaub allergiker wissen
wahrscheinlich auch wovon ich spreche
wenn ich sage dass beim staubsaugen kind
man sieht's nicht aber natürlich riecht
man ist und da kommt einfach der ganze
feinstaub wieder raus und für
hausstauballergiker ist es natürlich
nicht ganz so gut deswegen bin ich ganz
froh dass wir bald unsere zentrale
staubsauger anlage benutzen können
ich würde am liebsten hier schon gerne
einbauen aber das wäre schwachsinnig das
macht man wirklich nur dann wenn man
entweder neu baut oder einfach sein haus
oder die wohnung renoviert dann macht
das ganze sinn und ist auch wirklich
sehr praktisch ihr seht ihr zimmer seien
ungefähr ein querschnitt von unserem
neuen haus
ihr wisst hier vorne in dem bereich
arbeiten wir unsere youtube videos
drehen das sind auch die mitarbeiter
büros und obendrüber wohnen und meine
eltern hinten im bereich ist unser haus
wir haben ja zwei stockwerke und da wäre
es im prinzip auch schon so dass wir
mindestens vier staubsauger schon hätten
plus einen staubsauger der dann noch in
der garage ist das heißt wir müssen uns
fünf staubsauger anschaffen um nicht
ständig den staubsauger treppe rauf und
treppe runter zu tragen
und wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle ich
müsste jetzt fünf staubsauger kaufen da
bin ich mit einer zentralen staubsauger
anlage sogar kostenmäßig wirklich viel
viel besser dran kostet im endeffekt zur
b15 1600 euro und vor allem braucht
meine mama zum beispiel gar keinen
staubsauger besorgen sie bekommt einfach
ein schlauch für ihre wohnung und das
ganze ist ja dann später also die
komplette anlage ist im technikraum das
heißt man hat den vorteil man hat zu
hause beim staubsaugen einfach nichts
mehr
man hat den feinstaub nicht man stolpert
über keine kabel und über keine
schläuche und das ganze ist wirklich
super praktisch wir haben uns jetzt beim
anbieter für die firma thomas
entschieden
die haben wir jetzt auch schon auf der
ifa kennengelernt auch schon zum zweiten
oder dritten mal sogar und ich habe mich
einfach für die firma entschieden weil
es eine deutsche firma ist und es ist
wirklich ein familienunternehmen gibt es
schon seit jahrzehnten und ich ganz so
einfach sicher sein dass die produkte
wirklich auch langlebig sind und wenn
doch mal was sein sollte dann habe ich
einfach einen ansprechpartner ich habe
den service und die ersatzteile sind
immer vor ort
ich glaube jetzt habe ich genug geredet
ich kann euch natürlich noch nicht
zeigen
die das ganze bei uns auf der baustelle
aussieht da zeige ich euch später aber
den einbau jetzt haben wir mal kurz zu
meiner freundin die hat nämlich die
zentral staubsauger anlage da kann ich
euch zeigen wie das schlauch aussieht
wie das ganze zu bedienen ist der borat
kann es auch gleich mal ausprobieren und
deswegen nehme ich euch jetzt mal mit
ich finde jetzt grad weiter mama von
meiner freundin lena und der hat eine
zentrale stoff sorge anlage und die kann
ich euch gleich mal zeigen die lena die
sieht man hier übrigens im hintergrund
da umarmen aber ich muss mit lehrer
schimpfen und jetzt gar kein foto von
uns stehen dir gegeben
ja lena die mission foto von uns dahin
hängen muss ausruhen dann aber mehr
geben
ich gehe mal zum staubsauger also ja
jetzt schon mal den staubsauger schlaf
und den stab und zwar ist bei der firma
thomas ist finde ich auch echt ganz gut
ich das sind wirklich ganz ganz leichter
schlauch und zwar deswegen weil der stab
über funk funktioniert das heißt ich
kann denn hier an und ausschalten und
auch die saugkraft steuern und das ganze
funktioniert eben über funk bei den
meisten anderen produkten ist es so dass
da ein kabel mit drin steckt dadurch der
schlauch auch extrem schwer wird und
eben dann auch nicht so schön flexibel
ist und das finde ich echt gut dass ich
habe das ganze jetzt vorne schon
eingesteckt und jetzt kann ich einfach
sagen
und ihr hört jetzt auch schon mal hatte
im prinzip fast nur die reibung auf dem
boden also wenn ich den sauger einfach
anheben
das geräusch ist gar nicht so laut also
echt gut dass der murat kann saugen und
die kinder können neben herrscht orten
oder ich kann sorgen und dem rad kann
einfach in ruhe fußball gucken
jetzt kann ich ihn einfach ausschalten
jetzt bin ich fertig und normalerweise
ist es bei uns zu hause beim saugen
immer so wir sorgen ohne stunde später
liegt wieder überall der ganze staub
weil einfach aus dem staubsauger beutel
das ganze hinten aus dem staubsauger
wieder heraus gepustet wird jetzt haben
wir das problem hier nicht mehr weil
wirklich der ganze staub komplett
weggezogen wird in die anlage und ja
lena oder thermisch nicht angesteckt
deswegen haben wir das ganze jetzt bei
uns auch fürs haus geplant und wir
fahren jetzt mal gemeinsam auf die
baustelle und ich zeige euch wie einfach
die installation geht
wir sind jetzt auf der baustelle und
jetzt zeige ich euch wie man die
zentrale staubsauger anlage eingebaut
das ist wirklich super einfach aber im
vorfeld muss man sich natürlich
überlegen wo möchte ich ihn über all
diese auf dosen haben also die schläuche
die sind ja acht oder zehn meter lang
das heißt man muss einmal überlegen wo
brauche ich denn überhaupt schläuche
brauche ich sie in jedem raum oder
reicht es zum beispiel auch bei einem
kleinen haus nur im flur das heißt
während es vorgemacht mit murat ich habe
einfach überlegt ok in der küche auf
jeden fall in den bädern oder im
schlafzimmer und habe mir dann eine
schnur an die wand geklebt die daneben
acht meter lang war und bin dann so die
räume mit der schnur abgelaufen und habe
überlegt wo komm ich jetzt ganz
komfortabel hin mit dem schlauch wir
haben dann aber trotzdem nochmal unseren
plan eingereicht bei thomas dennis nicht
wirklich die experten und wenn man da
wirklich nicht ganz sicher ist da gibts
da auch ein planung service da kann man
sich dran wenden und die haben das ganze
dann auch noch ein bisschen optimiert
ich habe sogar zwei drei dosen gespart
sozusagen und jetzt werden die gleich an
die wand eingezeichnet ganz wichtig ist
nämlich dass man das ganze dann
installiert wenn zum beispiel auch
gerade die heizungsrohre und die
abwasserrohre installiert werden
dann ist der perfekte zeitpunkt und ich
zeige mich jetzt hier hinten einmal so
wie wir das ganze installieren werden
hier sitzt eine saug stelle
eingezeichnet und die wir jetzt hier an
die wand angebracht und jetzt muss ich
natürlich überlegen auf welche höhe muss
diese sau klose ganz komfortabel ist
eine höhe von 60 cm
da muss man sich später einfach nicht so
sehr drücken um den schlauch hier
anzubringen
daher ist 60 cm damit sie aber gerade
noch keinen fußboden drin das heißt ich
muss noch überlegen
17 zentimeter muss ich das so rechnen
und bin dann eben auch eine höhe von 77
cm und gehe dann einfach von der wand 20
zentimeter rein und das kann ich jetzt
kurz an zeichnen
ja und dann geht es schon direkt los als
es hier
wirklich zu vereinbaren ist sehr
unkompliziert jetzt wird es mir
allerdings zu machen kommt die sonne
raus also jetzt wird an gezeichnet
jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet und
kann die schlitze klopfen und am ende
kommen ganz normale abwasserrohre in die
wand das heißt ihr braucht keine spezial
rohre und der vorteil ist die kann man
einfach zusammenstecken und die müssen
nicht geklebt werden
was ich auch ganz gut findet dass noch
diese anlage keine kabel verlegen muss
weil das ganze über funk funktioniert
das heißt ich spar arbeitskosten und
natürlich auch material also jetzt kann
ich anfangen wo jetzt meine
arbeitskleidung und dann wird gefräst
hier seht jetzt der montage haben also
einmal mit dem abwasser und hier oben
dann eben mit dem putz der gelder
stecken bleibt jetzt natürlich drauf wie
es die komplette wand verputzt ist und
später kommt da einfach die sorglose
dran
jetzt muss ich hier den schlitz noch ein
bisschen tiefer klopfen damit ich
einfach das abwasserrohr schön darin
versenken kann und später wird es dann
hier noch dran geschraubt und wie gesagt
dann sind wir schon fertig ihr könnt es
gerne zu hause so wie wir jetzt auch
alleine machen oder ihr holt euch
einfach jemanden vom krach falls ihr
eben zu hause nicht selber handwerk
jetzt muss ich mal gucken ob das
überhaupt rein passt aber ich das gut
finden kann
fast perfekt jetzt kann ich da oben
weiter machen und es geht wirklich super
einfach da der öltank steinmeiers der
weich ist und ich wirklich wie bei der
werkzeug auch in der torte einfach das
ganze schön ausschauen kann
bevor der montage rahmen und das
abwasserrohr hier dran gebracht werden
muss ich das abwasserrohr noch einpacken
und zwar in so einem schutz schlau
jetzt könnt ihr euch nämlich vorstellen
wenn wir zum beispiel später zu hause
sagen und beispielsweise kleine
kieselsteine mit einsaugen dann wird man
das gehören in diesem abwasserrohr weil
es ja aus kunststoff besteht daher muss
man das ganze tier schützen
reinsetzen und dann hat man eben keinen
körperschall in der wand jetzt kann ich
denn montage rahmen montieren und da ist
jetzt ganz wichtig dass er ganz genau
arbeitet denn das ganze muss später in
der waage sein also richtig schön gerade
denn wenn das jetzt nicht gerade ist es
auch später die hauptlese nicht gerade
von daher muss es da wirklich supergut
arbeiten unterbrechen auch mit einer
wasserwaage
sonst ärgert ihr euch später
so und ich habe am ende das heißt sie
sind nicht so hart da kann ich jetzt
ohne bohrmaschine arbeiten aber falls er
zum beispiel xun steilwände habt müsst
ihr natürlich bohren ich nehme jetzt
einfach ein schraubenzieher und den
hammer und kann jetzt die löcher einfach
einschlagen
und dann nehmen wir einfach mit dem
hauptpreis
schon jetzt kann ich auch schon an
schrauben
bei uns sind jetzt alle montage rahmen
in der waage jetzt werden die rohre
verlegt da müsst ihr jetzt im prinzip
nur an eines denken und zwar solltet ihr
keine 90 grad winkel haben sondern 45
das heißt bei uns hier kann das jetzt so
verlegt werden und so ich einfach
gewährleistet dass die saugkraft sehr
stark ist und dass zum beispiel auch
keine verstopfungen entstehen können im
nächsten schritt kann dann jetzt der
verputzer kommen und alles verputzen
natürlich muss dann erst mal noch unser
häuschen fertiggestellt werden und wenn
dann alles fertig ist wenn die fußböden
drinnen sind die wände verputzt sind
kommt am ende dann eben auch die
zentrale staubsauger anlage bei uns in
den technikraum und dann kann ich auch
zeigen wie sie bei uns zuhause
funktioniert ja ich denke unser haus
wird eines der innovativsten aber auch
eines der nachhaltigsten häuser
deutschlandweit werden
irgend könnt dann wirklich sehen was man
alles mit smartphone machen kann und was
man alles auch überhaupt mit technik
anstellen kann ohne dass es aber zu viel
schnickschnack wird also alles was wir
einbauen ist wirklich sehr sinnvoll und
nicht einfach nur irgendeine spielerei
und ich hoffe euch hat dieses video
gefallen und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal wieder zwischendurch kommen
natürlich ganz üblich wie immer meine
rezepte und dann folgt schon ganz bald
mein nächstes update also bis zum
nächsten mal
mit dem ding erstaunlich kräfte apple
nicht ein
doch hier noch funktioniert so machst du
auch machst du das machen weist die
falschen leute genau richtig für den
staubsauger
ja sie doch das muss für den staubsauger
sag mal den hier ein anderer ist nicht
so breit wie der alte staubsauger
geizkragen war günstiger das ist falsch
das war günstig wie beim 107 und wir
haben jetzt m40 kann ich machen wollte
sich den anderen wieder benutzen